ma sti cazzi questo che è un mix di
pollo ovunque vestito da d'apollo ferida
nonna però che ciò sotto scacco la
console pollo giro
ciao ragazzi bentornati non ho puntata
di cucina buttata oggi faremo il pollo
fritto di terzi che sia chiaro prima che
se pensi che qua tutti quanti fanno i
fisico che come fanno su instagram che
si aggiungono dopo i suoni dei croc che
so patetici noi qua facciamo europa
verità non abbiamo bisogno di aggiungere
suoni diversi il pollo che ci è arrivato
di kfc appena lo prendi lì per lì è
buono dopo dieci minuti che ti arriva in
ufficio è una roba immonda beh ma in
generale tutti i fritti so così è ma che
oggi è un filo di perdere non ti poteva
capitare questo 37 e mezzo safe che non
è da piede nella fossa ma nemmeno
vengono ufficio questo qui è il morso
instagram
consenti come crocca
[Musica]
questo è morso reale invece
è buono noi oggi
abbiamo cercato varie ricette in tanti
ci hanno raccontato della storia di
casey dei suoi segreti che sono stai
centri anch'esso a stare pensi io ho
trovato forse quella che potrebbe essere
la ricetta che più si avvicina a potersi
vuol dire che alla fine che in tali fra
circa carissimo ma sti cazzi iniziamo
con la ricetta per prima cosa dovremo
creare un bagno la marinatura buon
intingolo un intingolo king in rai
natura
il latte io lo uso parzialmente scremato
perché almeno l'impressione di essere
più dietetico tirarci una vera re cioè
che mi caso la vostra bilancia tanto
critiche che tiene appunto due uova si
crea una sorta di ea 15 e mezza
forchetta qua sotto c'è di tutto e di
più se vuoi posso usare il coso
realizzata la prende un po di sale
trovato trovato tra ferri da nonna però
che c'è sotto un pochino di sale
oddio
tt non ce lo potevamo permettere una
forchetta una socia un'amica pinza cioè
tutto era sempre salvano un cazzo in
mano quando solo pollo gilotta
questo qui intanto lo abbiamo infilato
all'interno desto bagnetto step
successivo è infilarlo in frigo coperto
per 30 minuti torniamo qua reso sicuro
che il nostro sarà molto più buono di te
colori se non li fate a casa paternostro
andate a meno che casey nome paghino
domani stocker dycker polo del mondo ha
vestito da d'apollo
rocker si è buono
caro 2 varie
32 euro per un bar di un budget qua
dentro
ma gli score c'è culo
follia ragazzi che appunto cazzo che gli
elfi che kurt io vado ragazzi e se qui
sono degli strumenti secondo me
utilissimi perché vi aiutano quando
prendete le ricette straniere
dal vivo che ai piani quindi vi lascio
qua sotto in descrizione quelle cose che
costano pulire e di svoltano per il
resto della vita buona
tazza ok allora ragazzi masseria quattro
tazze e che 2
vabbè che a metà della dell'opera è a
metà dell'opera ac a metà dell'opera è a
metà dell'opera
ibra piano famiglie perché ci stanno
avendo porca miseria foto ormai poter
più fetente mezza cosa e cerca di
vendere qualcosa ma io ho venduto le
date
dei cibi leggeri del cavallo c'è un post
capito una cosa pronto 5 cucchiaini di
sale
234 sembra ultimo come ultimo ma un
ultimo ma ultimo 2 cucchiai di una
spezia segreta e astratta di rate pari
al pop le parate a carta [ __ ] di una
ragazza dicono che sia la spezia che ti
katsina storia è stata tolta dal mercato
perché che il sì non voleva più il
colonnello poi lui è questo che è un mix
di bellezza di tutto tutto prendiamo il
mix e loro dicono di metterci due
cucchiai però dalle ricerche ho fatto
due cucchiai risultano tirar fuori un
sapore più lieve avvio azzardo 3
cucchiai by daniela ghazi ma io qua con
te ho girate ho girato ho capito pure
vuole il problema sono a dieta
quindicenne e mento dei [ __ ]
infinito no dai non ti butta giù così
[Musica]
sono a dieta io prendo un meraviglioso
pentolino che potrete acquistare
troviamo il modico prezzo e vi presenta
una sua funzionalità pazzesca dell'olio
di semi di soia o
nel olio di frittura questo mi fa ride
un po non riesco a capire in che modo
possa funzionare mariga ma qua sotto c'è
ovviamente pure non so dumas ioni l'asse
da stiro uno dei consigli che vengono
dati all'interno dei vari vide i che si
trovano online è quello di aggiungere il
succo di limone all'olio di cottura e
questo perché per avvicinare ancora di
più il sapore quello del pollo fritto
ripensi rubato ma che bello quel prezzo
però pensai che fosse per per strane
altro invece no è arrivato il momento di
riportare quel pollo al e baidu
grasso prendersela con come pure a
prender scusa solo una cosa devono
chiedere non finisce mai di fargli
licheri questa
che è successo non vede cosa accerchia
dell'asta cucina una serie di spilli
verticali sui quali vengono messi in
equilibrio basso i piatti ok ragazzi io
nel frattempo porto l'olio in
temperatura ancora più grande al papa a
fare in culo
porto nonio a temperatura ambiente
qualcuna acqua e la pizzetta perché qua
sotto sicuramente trovo un po da erba ma
non trovo allora ragazzi ci siamo dai
tranquilli no è tutto sereno ecco è
questo per termometro
170 mettiamola in tra parentesi questo
qui è utilissimo in cucina il rilascio
qua sotto il link affiliato
con il dubbio vado salviamo prima con
con temperatura o temperatura o facciamo
salire timbratura
che
il futuro intanto faccio questo questo
è
bello porn però non fa per quanto ma ci
butto dentro razzi questa è la prima
prova questa prima frittura non sta
andando come vorrei partito è il mio kfc
sarà indubbiamente
sì che guarda a o porca [ __ ] mi sto
facendo malissimo la parte che tocca il
fornello e diventa più una gratifica è
sempre piaciuta risulta anche sempre
asciutta
se non è che sia proprio benissimo
raga io non so vi giuro
sto cercando degli omini si è cotto
dentro dovrebbe essere cotto dentro a 80
gradi ma dentro siamo al 75
non è accorto allora
e carine è una risata riuscitissima
adesso proviamo un'altra tecnica allora
prendiamo questo e lo buttiamo qualche
voi vivete vabbè fin qui l'abbiamo già
visto un violino caro step successivo
prendiamo questa la immergiamo
nell'acqua ci va
di nuovo a un grande senso
qualcuno da casa si può suggerire dei
metodi reali per fare delle impanature e
friggere perché netto no guarda questa
ma chiedere aiuto e giustamente è una
temperatura fra particolare con la roma
vista l'ho scoperta online posso dire
che già a faccia è diversa sta
migliorando quindi secondo me è solo le
tempistiche di cottura che permettono
ogni volta in crisi no è che sto
cercando da cinque secoli piede inutili
dello schermo è lì quindi sono delle
mani noi le mani dai piedi partiamo
dalle
torri gosso professato di essere un
feticista ma in realtà
vabbè dai trionfi eder ricostruzione
semplicemente di fare il sito no no no
c'è un piede ma che c'entra un piano
della farina riconoscenza ragazzi in
tutto ciò se anche voi avete visto un
piede nella farina scriveteci il piede
nella farina per favore sotto questo
video
eccoci qui la mano due mani
dopo
un cazzo cento dei pietre sentite la
puntata
e questo è il risultato finale ragazzi
secondoi qualcosa che il si con il
nostro cioè qual è più bello e qual è
più brutto onesti sono di civili è
il colonnello che da 50 anni cioè dal
calcio questo è il nostro posto il kers
e direi a questo punto di fare un
assaggio ho iniziato dicendo una cosa
che sul web che chiedono sempre i sordi
e degli stalli con la carta di credito
io vi chiedo una cosa che gratis online
l'iscrizione è anche un commento
condividiamo anche questo video allora
assaggio primario
è interessante il pollo a me è una
canzone che ammorba è un po come farsi
un pomeriggio con graziana un'ora va
bene ma immaginate di 12 ore di graziana
assaggiamo
questo fammi un crack
[Musica]
non
basta
io ogni puntata più gruppo una persona
che assaggi la persona che assaggerà è
la vigna il bancone
di un assaggino
da walter nardin
vicina dettagli un morso consistenza un
bel successo
ragazzi per dire cosa ho detto io che
avrei fatto meglio essere perduti spa
come lo sa è un orgasmo perché dentro il
morbidissimo guarda super cotta e fuori
e francia scusami se ti ho trattato per
tutto il video è successa un'altra
persona prima di me gesù
ragazzi siamo lieti di questo video mi
raccomando se li farete cosa che vi
invito a fare pagatemi su instagram e
delle nostre storie io sono pronto a
dimostrarlo ovunque commentarle ragazzi
ci vediamo domenica prossima con una
puntata induce buttata alle 12 ciao
[Musica]
no
[Applauso]
[Musica]